sources tell CBS News the accused gunman
left 180 rounds of ammunition inside the
school along with his rifle officials
also say they found swastikas on the
magazines for his bullets Manuel
Bojorquez is in parkland hearing from
one of the last people to see the
suspect before the massacre Manuel good
morning good morning the uber driver who
dropped off Nicholas Cruz at the high
school the day of the shooting is
speaking out for the first time she says
she did not notice anything strange
about him during the 13 minute trip and
is now worried about the types of
weapons her passengers could be carrying
this is the car Nicholas Cruz rode into
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
just after 2:00 p.m. the uber driver who
picked him up has asked that we not
share her identity I saw him with the
backpack that I think it was a guitar
case I am going to my music class about
two minutes after arriving police say
the suspect entered classroom building
12 and began shooting less than seven
minutes later sources familiar with the
investigation tell CBS News the
suspected gunman was on the building's
third floor when he fired 16 rounds at a
stairwell window trying to hit people
below but sources say bullets failed to
pierce through the windows
hurricane-proof class the suspects
weapon is then believed to have jammed
while reloading sources say the alleged
shooter dropped his weapon and
ammunition before exiting the building
hiding among students running for safety
Florida Governor Rick Scott is vowing to
pass a school safety bill before the
state's annual legislative session ends
next Friday his 500 million dollars
statewide plan includes increasing law
enforcement and mental health counselors
at schools in Tallahassee victim's
parents urged legislators to advocate
for stricter gun safety measures our
nation's children deserve better
Mac Schachter's 14 year old son Alex was
killed in the Parkland school shooting
and if we would have had these measures
in place I would not have to have buried
my son next to his mother a week and a
half ago
the governor is expected to announce
more details of a school safety plan at
a news conference later this morning the
uber driver was contacted by Broward
County deputies and has been cleared of
the investigation Alex
Manuel thanks